if you were spending hundreds of
millions of dollars to send weapons to a
foreign country it would probably pay to
keep track of them but apparently that's
the last thing that was on the
Pentagon's mind when it came to
operation inherent resolve in Syria
special operations joined task force
operation inherent resolve personnel did
not account for the budget is seven
hundred and fifteen point eight million
of counter Isis trained and equipped
fund equipment for fiscal years 2017 and
2018 hundreds of weapons were not
properly stored duplicate purchases were
made the amount spent went higher and
higher now that might give critics of
the military-industrial complex
something to complain about but that's
not the crux of the problem here take a
listen to this special operations Joint
Task Force operation inherent resolve
and first thereto sustainment command
personnel left thousands of counter Isis
trained and equipped from weapons and
sensitive equipment items vulnerable to
loss or theft without conducting
consistent inventories and ensuring
proper security for CTFs equipment first
TSC could not determine whether items
were lost or stolen which could delay
the initiation of an investigation so
let's be clear they're saying they're
not 100% sure that these weapons ended
up in the hands of Isis terrorists but
that there's a pretty good chance they
did
now that should raise plenty of
questions especially for those who
recall that back in 2017 the so-called
vetted opposition was getting stock
loads of handouts in weapons from the
Pentagon
the original fiscal year 2017
President's budget request for train and
equip efforts in Syria funds training
and equipment for about 14,000 partner
force troops from the vetted Syrian
opposition seems like some of these
vetted opposition we're not really
interested in fighting the ISIL
terrorists they just focused on their
ongoing efforts to violently overthrow
the Syrian government one of our partner
forces there unilaterally conducted
patrols outside of the agreed-upon
de-escalation zone and engaged in
activities not focused on fighting Isis
it seems like American weapon
pretty consistently end up not in the
hands of anti-terrorist fighters but in
the hands of terrorists themselves
let's see what's been captured
to talk you are
715 million dollars can buy a lot of
ammunition
now when that much goes missing in a
war-torn country that's crawling with
terrorists eyebrows should be raised for
comparison the Republic of the Congo and
Ghana spend less than 715 million
dollars in their annual military budgets
Latvia spends slightly more in 2017
approximately 1 billion dollars worth of
arms transfers were not properly
monitored by the Pentagon big mistakes
were made in this arm and equip program
it partly is an accounting issue because
the Pentagon as we know has never been
successfully audited they tried to audit
the Pentagon once and it was an absolute
failure they have no idea where the
money goes and that's one half of the
problem they just don't care because
it's not about defense it's about first
of all the military-industrial complex
the more weapons you lose the more you
can buy and it's this kind of symbiosis
though the war machine in Washington has
so that is on one hand but on the other
hand I think there's an intentional lack
of oversight with regard to weapons in
Syria we've seen so many times advanced
American military technology in the
hands of Isis and al Qaeda and their
offshoots in the region there's been a
flood of weapons into the region there
are no consequences to the u.s. it's
only a benefit to the well politically
connected military-industrial complex in
Washington DC to manufacture and send
over more weapons they don't care about
the misery of the people on the ground
you have to suffer US leaders frequently
describe their operations in the Middle
East as efforts to stabilize the region
but nothing brings stability like going
into war-torn countries crawling with
terrorists bringing in hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of weapons and
then accidentally losing them caleb
Maupin RT New York